hey this is pressure Walker in a barn
100 chicks sit peacefully in a circle
suddenly each chick randomly pecks the
chick immediately to its left or right
what is the expected number of unpacked
chicks this problem was asked today in
the 2017 Raytheon national math counts
competition as reported in the New York
Times a 13 year old buzzed in in under a
second and got the correct answer to win
a $20,000 scholarship when I was in
grade school I have done math towns
competitions and I was never that good
at solving these problems
congratulations to the winner in this
video I'm going to ask you can you
figure out what the answer to this
problem is give this problem a try and
when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution the answer is 25
chicks intuitively a chick is not pecked
if it only if the chick to its left
pecks left and the chip to its right
pecks right I will illustrate this in a
simple example of four chicks around a
circle focus on the chick in the bottom
of the circle in order that this chick
is not packed
we need the chick to its left to peck
left and we need the chick to it's right
to peck right what is the probability of
this happening assuming each chick pecks
in a direction with a 1/2 chance there's
a 1/2 chance the left chick text left
and 1/2 chance the right chick pecks
right thus there is a 1/2 times 1/2
which equals 1/4 chance that a chick is
not pecked as this is true for every
single chick we expect 1/4 of the chicks
not
detect meaning there will be 100 times
1/4 which is equal to 25 unpacked chicks
so that's the answer as written in the
competition however I'm going to be
pedantic and say the question is
technically unsolvable as stated the
details aren't important look again at
the wording of the question it is stated
that each chick randomly pecks the chick
immediately to its left or right but
what does randomly pecks mean it's
actually a vague term a chick that pecks
left with a 1% chance and right with a
99% chance also randomly pecks to its
left or right the problem should have
stated randomly pecks to each direction
with equal chance furthermore we also to
know whether each chick randomly texts
using the same probability distribution
one chick might be flipping a coin which
means a 50% chance to peck left to right
but another chick might be rolling a
dice for a single number which means a
1/6 chance to peck left and 5/6 chance
to peck right for the purpose of this
problem we'll assume that each chick is
using the same probability distribution
but even with that caveat we still have
the issue that we need to know the
probability that each chick pecks left
or right and the exact probability will
affect the ultimate answer as I'll
explain in the next few slides so let's
solve the problem formally if you've
been watching my videos you should know
how to solve this the problem is very
much like the video about guessing on a
matching test or figuring out how many
shuffle cards do not move in a random
shuffle well number the checks from 1 to
100 and index them by the variable I
will define a random variable X sub I to
equal 0 if the chick is pecked and 1 if
the chick is unpacked let's define the
probability a chick pecks left to equal
P and the probability a chick pecks
right
two equal one minus P these are
complementary events because we know the
chick is pecking in some direction we
now compute the expected value of x sub
I by definition this is equal to zero
times the probability of check respect
and one times the probability a chick is
unpacked this simplifies to be the
probability a chick is unpacked as
stated before this depends on the
probabilities that the chick on the Left
pecks left and the probability the chick
on the right X right this will be equal
to P times 1 minus P we now need to
figure out how many chicks are expected
to be unpacked this will be the expected
value of the sum of the random variables
this will be equal to the sum of the
expectations this is the beautiful
property of the linearity of the
expectation operator and that's going to
allow us to solve this problem now we
figured out the expected value of each X
of I is equal to P times 1 minus P so we
can substitute in this single value for
each of these hundred different
expectations we now have a hundred terms
of P times 1 minus P now this will
actually depend on the variable P when
you have lower values of P and higher
values of P it will deviate from the
maximum value of 25 when P is equal to
50% or 0.5 the answer is 25 unpacked
chicks but the answer does depend on the
variable P so this is the more general
and what I would consider to be the
formal problem solving to this question
which was a little bit vague but
nevertheless if you were in a
competition you would have to guess that
the probability was 50% to go left to
right and you would get to the answer 25
now whether you'd be able to solve it in
less than a second it's not something I
can do but congratulations to the winner
did you
and how long did it take you thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch around my blog
mind your decisions that you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you like this video please
check out my books